la Nouvelle-Orléans souffre d'une
violence chronique un homme sur 86 est
en prison dans la plupart des cas il est
noir pourtant la ville ancienne colonie
française attire des touristes du monde
entier ici la musique est sur tout le
jazz sont rois dans les ruelles de la
vieille ville l'alcool coule à flot on
s'enivre on sent qu'elle aille
située en partie au-dessous du niveau de
la mer la ville s'allenguille dans
l'immense Bayou elle émet entre
paresseux du Mississippi le plus grand
fleuve des États-Unis
ici la justice et la police sont sans
pitié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la Nouvelle-Orléans les armes parlent
souvent plus vite que les hommes je vais
suivre les policiers de plaque mind dans
la banlieue sud de la ville où une
opération de routine peut vite tourner à
la fusillade j'irai dans un gun show ou
n'importe qui peut t'acheter de quoi
tuer son voisin donc ça c'est le
pistolet d'Elvis Presley avec une grosse
en nacre
je découvrirai une police débordée par
l'ampleur de sa tâche une police
redoutée pour son penchant à faire feu
sans sommation
dans la nuit de la Nouvelle-Orléans je
sillonnerait les ruelles du quartier
français j'ai rencontré Sidney Torres à
un millionnaire qui a créé sa propre
police
on est en sécurité oui et c'est grâce à
lui
avec zakarpenter un avocat commis
d'office je plongerai dans la machine à
mettre en prison
ici on donne les peines les plus lourdes
de tous les États-Unis c'est injuste
mais c'est comme ça
j'entrerai dans les prisons de la ville
l'ancienne qui sent l'urine et la
nouvelle trop propre
je suis vrai les pis skippers ces
militants noirs qui se battent pour le
respect de leurs droits les pouvoirs en
place je veux dire le pouvoir blanc
n'acceptera jamais d'accorder l'égalité
à ses anciens esclaves jamais notre père
nous sommes venus aujourd'hui au nom de
Jésus pour que tu bénisses notre
communauté plonger dans une ville où la
violence des hommes n'a rien à envier à
celle des éléments quand les dix bons CD
c'est la société entière qui a cédé
moi j'avais l'impression que c'était la
fin du monde on aurait dit The Walking
Dead la police patrouillée pour tuer ce
qui ressemblait à des zombies
je me suis penché pour attraper le
panier
et j'ai entendu
bienvenue à La Nouvelle-Orléans avec en
poche un passeport pour le crime
la Nouvelle-Orléans et la capitale
culturelle de la Louisiane
ce n'est pas une vie immense
380 000 habitants taux d'homicide 40
fois supérieur à Paris
ensuite on va rester en tension pour
toute la durée de la séance je ne suis
pas dans un camp militaire mais
simplement dans un stand d'entraînement
de la police
ici on n'est pas vraiment dans
l'appréhension la dissuasion mais dans
l'efficacité
c'est réglé là s'il y a eu deux impacts
dans la poitrine parfois il y a pas
d'effet et des gens peuvent continuer à
se battre donc tu tires là deux fois si
jamais ça ne marche pas parce que des
fois le gars est calmé ou il a un gilet
pare-balles alors tu tire dans la tête
et là c'est fini jamais dans les jambes
d'abord non jamais les jambes jamais
nous on tire ici
pour se tenir en forme on ne lisigne pas
sur les séances de tir qui ont lieu une
semaine sur deux
[Applaudissements]
et on ne légitime pas la dépense côté
cartouche plus de 1000 tirés à chaque
séance
un exercice qui fait appel à l'instant
au réflexe plus qu'aux ressources
cérébrales
avec la pratique dès que quelque chose
va se présenter en face de toi c'est ton
système réflexe qui va te placer tout de
suite en mode combat on appelle ça la
mémoire musculaire c'est automatique
en situation d'urgence ton corps va
réagir avant ton cerveau
au cas où les choses tourneraient mal
l'équipe dispose d'un véhicule blindé
moitié Mad Max moitié Robocop ce monstre
résiste même aux attaques chimiques on
ne sait jamais
ça s'appelle un bercat c'est un véhicule
armé de secours mais vous utilisez ce
véhicule à quelle occasion
si quelqu'un est touché par balle en
particulier par un sniper on peut venir
se placer entre le tireur et le blesser
on peut tirer depuis le véhicule ah on
peut tirer depuis l'intérieur
on doit se sentir invincible là-dedans
non on est invulnérable complètement
vulnérable
on peut nous tirer dessus avec une
mitrailleuse de gros calibre et nous on
leur fait
coup de ce joujou sophistiqué presque
1/2 millions d'euros un cadeau du
Homeland Security débattement
l'organisme qui depuis le 11 septembre
2001 fédère les services de sécurité à
travers le pays
les gens pensent qu'on est là pour leur
confisquer leur arme mais ils se trompe
nous on aime les armes on est tous
membres de la NRS
mais c'est vrai que ce véhicule il est
très dissuasif et ça calme tout de suite
le jeu
à la Nouvelle-Orléans si la police
déploie tant de moyens pour assurer la
sécurité elle n'est pas forcément par
amour
il a moindre patrouille de routine peut
virer au drame et d'ailleurs les
officiers ne sortent jamais sans leur
gilet pare-balles
qu'est-ce qu'on est censé faire
maintenant
on va s'équiper et on va aller à
plusieurs adresses parce qu'on a des
mandats d'amener
on va aller chercher ces gens pour les
ramener avec nous
c'est bon
c'est ça
[Musique]
Richard et son collègue Brad on s'est
après midi une mission a priori de
routine ils doivent signifier à un homme
sa convocation devant le juge pour une
simple affaire d'alcool au volant
là on va voir un gars qui ne s'est pas
présenté devant le juge
on ne sait pas de quoi il est accusé on
sait juste qu'il ne s'est pas présenté
le quartier a l'air paisible on est au
milieu de l'après-midi pourtant Richard
se place instinctivement en couverture
de son collègue
bonjour monsieur bureau du shérif
c'est vous marque tous oui c'est moi
vous pouvez sortir pourquoi
sortez
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait allez ouvrir la
porte on a mandat d'amener
vous l'avez pas répondu à une
convocation je n'ai jamais reçu
j'ai rien reçu vous ne vous êtes pas
présenté devant le juge laissez moi
prendre une douche vite fait Marc
ouvrait cette porte mais pour une raison
inconnue l'homme refuse d'ouvrir je te
promets mon frère je veux juste prendre
une douche
Marc ouvrait cette porte
la tension monte d'un coup le désormais
forcené peut être armé
les renforts des boules de toute la
ville mais l'homme reste barricadé
tandis qu'en nous fait mettre à l'abri
de l'autre côté de la rue
de longues minutes s'écoule pendant
lesquelles les policiers tentent de
rétablir le contact avec l'homme
retranché derrière ses murs mais rien à
faire
le shérif l’oni Gréco arrive sur les
lieux il partage l'inquiétude générale
c'est un solitaire
et avec ce genre de profil
on ne sait jamais comment il peut réagir
[Musique]
coup de chance le shérif pense connaître
le beau-père du forcené
il appelle sa secrétaire
si je ne me trompe pas la fille de
Monsieur Deutsch habite dans cette
maison
je veux savoir si sa fille est dans la
maison et surtout s'il est armé
OK
[Musique]
si l'homme est armé les policiers
n'hésiteront pas à utiliser les grands
moyens
quelques minutes plus tard le beau-père
du forcenet rappelle
bonjour monsieur c'est bien votre fille
qui est marié avec Marcos
vous savez s'il a des armes dans la
maison
est-ce que vous pourriez l'appeler et
lui demander de venir me rejoindre à la
porte d'entrée
[Musique]
la maison est encerclée la police est
prête à donner l'assaut mais finalement
la situation se débloque quand le
beau-père arrive sur les lieux
fais pas le con Marc ton beau-père est
là lève les bras
l'intervention se termine sans un coup
de feu il n'est pas rare que des
policiers soit tués au cours d'opération
de ce type du coup les agents sont à
crampes ils ont la gâchette facile
allez-y doucement doucement je voulais
juste prendre une douche
tu aurais pas du temps fermer dans ta
maison c'est là que ça a mal tourné
mais je suis jamais sorti moi oui mais
quand tu as claqué la porte tout a
empiré regarde ton beau-père est là
ouais j'ai compris d'accord mais je suis
sorti non oui mais j'ai dû appeler ton
beau-père pour ça oui monsieur
calme-toi d'accord écoute le chérif
écoute-le il essaie de t'aider j'ai rien
fait de mal je sais que tu as rien fait
de mal
je voulais juste prendre une douche
c'est nul
je savais bien qu'il venait pour
m'arrêter
normalement refus d'obtempérer devrait
sérieusement aggraver la situation de ce
monsieur mais dans ce coin de la ville
tout le monde se connaît plus ou moins
et le shérif Greco est de bonne
compositions
il va se retrouver derrière les barreaux
pour quelques temps
et moi je vais aller avec son beau-père
pour voir son avocat
est-ce que vous allez utiliser le feu
qui n'a pas ouvert la porte comme une
circonstance aggravante
de toute façon ça se comprend les gens
ne sont jamais partants pour se faire
arrêter je suis juste content d'avoir
évité un bain de sang
[Musique]
classé depuis quelques années parmi les
villes les plus dangereuses du monde
juste derrière Bogota et devant Bagdad
au Kaboul la Nouvelle-Orléans nourrit
toutes les parano on sent convaincre il
suffit de lever le nez dans la rue
partout l'oeil de centaines de caméras
qui quadrillent la ville
un programme imaginé en 2003 par le
maire précédent qui se posait tant pour
vendeur du crime et qui végète
aujourd'hui en prison pour 10 ans car le
justicier était un voyou en col blanc il
a touché des pots de vin sur de nombreux
contrats d'équipements et de
reconstruction après Katrina sur les
1000 caméras commandées par la ville
seul 250 ont été installées plus la
moitié n'ont jamais fonctionné
alors ce sont des citoyens qui ont
repris l'affaire en main en créant le
projet Nola une association citoyenne
fondée par Brian Lagarde criminologue et
ancien flic
il a eu l'idée de mettre en réseau les
caméras des particuliers pour assurer la
surveillance de la ville
Nola analyse en permanence des heures
d'images qu'elle met à la disposition de
la Police
[Musique]
Brian installe aussi des caméras pour un
prix dérisoire aujourd'hui 1600 caméras
privés scrutent la Nouvelle-Orléans
si vous avez déjà une caméra on peut
mettre le signal en réseau si vous
n'avez pas de caméra on peut vous
équiper
et en général les gens mettent les
caméras à quel endroit
devant leur maison devant leur commerce
et ça nous permet de tout voir donc la
première personne que ça protège c'est
celui qui héberge la caméra et vu que
c'est de la HD on peut voir loin
quand il y a une caméra dans un endroit
où se déroule un crime on peut donner
l'information en temps réel à la police
Brian s'interrompt sur l'une des
fréquences radio de la police auxquelles
il est relié une voix tremblante attire
son attention
apparemment un policier est en
difficulté c'est la police
vous avez la radio de la police oui
excusez-moi j'ai besoin de deux minutes
je vais voir si on a besoin de moi
Bryan s'absente un instant le temps de
basculer sur l'un des écrans la caméra
la plus proche du lieu d'où provenait
l'alerte
un officier essayait de faire une
interpellation et là on le voit en live
on a ce qui se passe
j'ai juste entendu l'officier paniqué je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
en fait il était en train de pourchasser
un délinquant et il a eu des soucis mais
quel est votre idée de départ quand vous
décidez de créer le projet Nola
c'est ma façon de contribuer on savait
qu'en faisant ça on allait faire baisser
le nombre de crimes grâce à ce système
c'est plus facile d'identifier les
auteurs
au bureau du procureur ils adorent notre
travail car les gens ne peuvent plus
dire c'est pas moi et du coup ils vont
plaider coupable
un maillage qui n'évite pas le crime
mais qui complique un peu la vie des
voyous a posteriori
toutes ces photos racontent une histoire
tout ça ce sont des enquêtes pour
lesquelles on est intervenus
ça c'est après qu'ils aient sauvagement
agressé une vieille dame pour lui voler
son sac et qu'on s'est passé au tribunal
celui-là il a fallu qu'il explique
pourquoi il riait
non seulement il avait laissé sa victime
dans une mare de sang mais en plus il
rigolait il y prenait du plaisir
[Musique]
des fois on prouve que le crime n'a pas
eu lieu il y a des gens qui prétendent
avoir été détroussés mais c'est juste
pour cacher à leurs femmes qu'ils ont
dépensé l'argent pour acheter de la
drogue alors il raconte qu'on les a
volés et des fois les caméras sont
utiles pour innocenter les gens
[Musique]
on dirait une ambiance à la George nous
ne sommes pas le gouvernement nous ne
sommes pas la police et n'importe quel
citoyen peut participer en fait on est
juste le plus grand réseau de
surveillance citoyens au monde
imaginons que un détective vienne vous
demander des informations pour un client
qui a des soupçons sur la fidélité de sa
femme
je lui dirai navré pour vous maison ne
peut pas vous aider on donne seulement
nos images à la police ou alors pour les
urgences médicales
[Musique]
toujours bien placé dans le Guinness des
records la Nouvelle-Orléans arrive en
deuxième position pour le taux
d'homicide par armes à feu juste
derrière le Honduras
un statut peu enviable que Robert
Skinner auteur de polar et vieux
connaisseur de la ville explique assez
facilement
[Musique]
des armes
parce que tout le monde pense qu'un
homme doit être capable de défendre sa
maison les armes à la main
et surtout dans le Sud il y a beaucoup
de gens qui encouragent le port d'armes
ils obtiennent même des licences de
façon illégale
et ils ont leur arme dans la voiture
ce n'est pas un hasard s'il y a tant de
violence ici quand il y a autant d'armes
ça finit toujours par arriver
nous allons ensemble à un gunshu un
salon des armes à feu dans cette région
des États-Unis c'est aussi banal qu'un
salon de l'électroménager alors ici on
peut acheter une arme
absolument
c'est une des plus grandes controverses
du moment
on peut acheter des armes trop
facilement
[Musique]
comme c'est étrange on peut venir avec
les arbres il faut pas qu'elle soit
chargées et laisser les munitions dans
la voiture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on en trouve pour tous les âges pour
tous les goûts on vient en couple pour
choisir l'arme de Madame on vient aussi
en famille aussi décontracté que si on
visitait Disney armes de poings armes de
guerre n'importe qui peut acheter
n'importe quoi et ce sont ces armes qui
feront l'effet divers de demain
[Musique]
ça c'est un fusil avec un chargeur haute
capacité 9mm
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je vois
autant d'armes
et c'est parfaitement légal
ici il me faut une pièce d'identité
c'est tout oui et il vérifie juste que
vous n'avez pas de casier
vous devez habiter la Louisiane pour
acheter une arme chez nous
il faut que je sois résident un étranger
ne peut pas acheter d'armes
c'est moins cher comme marché noir en
France ou quoi
il suffit de deux ou trois cent euros
pour acheter une arme de points de
qualité mais parfois les consommateurs
sont prêts à débourser beaucoup plus
pour des armes lourdes dont on se
demande bien à quoi elle en servir et
les chers
[Musique]
moi j'y ai ajouté des accessoires
maintenant il doit valoir 1400 ou 1500
dollars
[Musique]
correspondant mon flingue
dans le sud des États-Unis la passion
populaire pour les armes ne connaît pas
de limites elles touchent tous les
milieux donc ça c'est le pistolet
d'Elvis Presley avec une crosse en nacre
[Musique]
les États-Unis c'est qu'ici on a une
image très romantique du héros populaire
qui porte une arme je ne pense pas qu'il
y a ça dans les autres pays
[Musique]
la Nouvelle-Orléans est depuis longtemps
une source d'inspiration pour les
auteurs de polar ou de séries policières
[Musique]
la ville a toujours été violente ou
c'est récent
niveau de violence ici
les gens qui travaillaient sur la
rivière c'était de vrais durs
il y avait aussi de jeunes créoles qui
imitaient leur semblable français
et qui s'offensaient pour rien
et vous provoquez en duel à l'épée
comment voit-on la Nouvelle-Orléans dans
le reste du pays les gens pensent que
c'est un endroit sauvage et la
Nouvelle-Orléans aime cette image un peu
sulfureuse d'elle-même c'est comme une
image de marque c'est ce qui fait de la
ville ce qu'elle est
c'est intéressant évidemment pour un
écrivain
[Musique]
les autorités préféreraient en finir
avec ce statut de ville la plus
dangereuse des États-Unis au début des
années 2000 la violence avait commencé à
baisser mais en 2005 avec la tempête
Katrina la criminalité repartie à la
hausse alors que faute d'argent public
les effectifs de la police étaient
réduits d'un tiers
[Musique]
10 ans plus tard la police est toujours
à la peine au cours du premier semestre
2015 on a comptabilisé 92 meurtres plus
30% par rapport à 2014
[Musique]
comme tous les mercredis voici le come
stade une conférence de la police
ouverte au public
durant laquelle les chefs de secteurs
les graines leur statistiques devant
leur chef
l'année dernière à la même époque on
avait déjà cinq meurtres en une semaine
et là on est à zéro il y a un progrès
on a huit vols de voiture dont une
voiture de livreur de pizza
bon ok les gars on fait un break
quelques minutes et on terminera après
oui bonjour je suis Christophe de la
télévision française
finalement la violence augmente ou elle
diminue
en ce moment elle diminue les chiffres
ont baissé mais pourquoi cette ville
est-elle la pire des États-Unis
pour la sécurité je ne pense pas que ce
soit vrai
c'est une idée de journaliste
c'est une perception que vous avez et
c'est une idée que vous aimez répondre
mais on n'est pas différent de n'importe
quel autre grandes villes quand vous
voyez des villes de notre taille il n'y
a pas de différence allez à Bâton Rouge
ou n'importe où ailleurs vous verrez la
même criminalité
il n'y a pas une violence particulière à
la Nouvelle-Orléans
différentes d'autres villes non
absolument pas ta gueule
[Musique]
circulez il y a rien à voir et si la
police tentait de minimiser les faits la
Nouvelle-Orléans Vita en grande partie
du tourisme et une mauvaise réputation
ça n'est jamais bon pour le commerce
quartier français
22h Carrefour d'Orléans Street et de
Bourbon Street le cœur de la fête
Dieu ne veut pas que vous alliez en
enfer s'il vous a donné le libre arbitre
ce n'est pas pour piloter votre vie
comme si on appuyait sur les boutons
d'une application si vous faites le mal
c'est parce que vous avez abandonné Dieu
à cet endroit
en vérité on est très loin de Dieu les
filles sont dénudées les gens déguisés
la musique déborde l'alcool est partout
ici c'est la fête 365 jours par an et
surtout pour Halloween on vient dans les
rues de la vieille ville pour s'enivrer
d'image de son et de sensualité
canailles
le French Quarter c'est le poumon
culturel et économique de la
Nouvelle-Orléans dans ce mouchoir de
poche d'un peu plus d'un kilomètre carré
les touristes génèrent près de 800
millions de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires par an
il y a à peine trois ans les voyous
sansonnettes à cœur joie il braquait les
fêtard dévaliser les boutiques les
appartements et la police arrivait
toujours trop tard
jusqu'à ce que le quartier trouve son
sauveur en 2012 en la personne de Sydney
Torres à riche entrepreneur local ce
soir pour la première fois Torres a été
bombardé roi de la parade
[Musique]
salut comment ça va
content de vous connaître c'était
comment c'était très bien
ça vous a plu qui vous a élu roi
c'est la ville
depuis Katrina Torres est connu comme le
loup blanc il a bâti sa fortune dans le
nettoyage de la ville après le Ouaga
c'était en 2005
6 ans plus tard le jeune millionnaire
est victime d'un cambriolage il dénonce
publiquement le manque de moyens de la
police pour se débarrasser des petites
frappes qui polluent son quartier il
crée une tasse force une brigade
d'intervention privée il investit dans
une application pour smartphone achète
trois voiturettes et embauche des
policiers en dehors de leurs heures de
service l'objectif est simple démontrer
que grâce aux nouvelles technologies et
avec un peu de bonne volonté on peut
réagir très vite
la french pass du quartier français vous
avertit des crimes en temps réel
l'application est un outil simple de
prévention du crime cette anonyme est
facile à utiliser si vous êtes témoin
d'une activité suspecte connectée
identifier la rue elle est décrivez la
situation et prenez une photo trois ans
plus tard le succès de sa tasforme a
ridiculisé le maire et fait de
signatores un héros
et attends comment tu t'appelles c'est
toi le gars qui ouais j'ai lu un article
sur toi c'est toi qui a monté cette
police privée dans le quartier français
oh moi aussi j'ai lu un article merci
beaucoup il y a pas de quoi on se sent
bien ici maintenant mais pourquoi est-ce
que vous dites ça parce que maintenant
il y a de la sécurité complètement et
c'est grâce à ce gars
vous êtes tous géniaux vous êtes une
sorte de vedette ici oui ils se sont en
sécurité ce soir on est en sécurité oui
et c'est grâce à lui ah c'est trop
gentil
merci beaucoup monsieur
bonne nuit
c'est incroyable là il y a un crime qui
vient de se produire vous voyez c'est
indiqué nouveau crime les gens qui sont
un peu agressifs
et quand tu cliques on voit l'image il y
a un trouble à l'ordre public
donc quelqu'un l'a signaler et ils ont
mis la photo et là la patrouille peut se
transporter sur les lieux et vous savez
où sont les voitures
elles sont juste là il y a une voiture
est en route
le nom de l'officier et il me dit son
positionnement exact
à ce jour
9800 personnes ont téléchargé
l'application dans les rues du quartier
français les agressions et les vols à
main armés ont chuté de 30%
mais les voiturettes de Sydney ne
sortent pas du French Quarter
ailleurs les effectifs de la police sont
partout en baisse et le crime partout en
hausse
la Nouvelle-Orléans compte moins
d'habitants que Toulouse mais en y
touche chaque année deux fois plus que
dans toute la région parisienne
dans le sud de la ville la banlieue
c'est le bayou et le bayou c'est le
delta du Mississippi à paradis pour
alligator et pêcheur de crevettes
le cadre est bucolique mais attention
ici aussi le crime est en embuscade et
la police veille
[Musique]
la commune de Black mind c'est la plus
vaste banlieue de la Nouvelle-Orléans
c'est ici que le Mississippi se
transforme en Bayou un labyrinthe de
terre et d'eau black mind c'est le
territoire du shérif lonigreco vous
souvenez l'homme qui résonne les forces
dit il est en pleine campagne pour sa
réélection aux États-Unis le chef de la
police est élu il est jugé pour ses
résultats et justement le shérif Gréco
est fier de son coup de filet il vient
d'arrêter une cinquantaine de personnes
en possession de drogue alors il a
convoqué la presse pour une conférence
qui ressemble furieusement à une
opération de séduction
bonjour monsieur dame comme vous devez
le savoir c'est ma quatrième saisie
depuis que je suis en fonction j'ai
accumulé plus de 1200 arrestations liées
à la drogue les trois dernières
opérations étaient opérations Unies
opération citrouille pourries opération
répression et celle-ci opération qui est
le prochain et effectivement on ne sait
jamais qui va être le prochain c'est
sans doute notre plus grande opération
d'infiltration nous avons arrêté 54
délinquants et saisi 227 g de marijuana
28 g de marijuana synthétique et 15 g
d'héroïne
rapporter au nombre de personnes
arrêtées les quantités de drogues sont
ridicules ces saisies relèvent plus de
la consommation personnelle que du
trafic
quand on regarde de près les quantités
de drogue saisies
ça n'a rien impressionnant
alors expliquez-nous pourquoi ces
arrestations sont aussi importantes
[Musique]
je ne sais pas exactement ce que ça
représente en dollars
mais même si les quantités sont petites
ça reste illégal
personne ne peut dire avec qui ces gens
ont été en contact et qu'ils pourraient
entraîner dans leur vie
ça pourrait être des enfants par exemple
sur cette terre ultra conservatrice le
shérif joue sur du velours il en rajoute
même
partout dans notre pays la drogue et le
fléau numéro 1
si quelqu'un voulait envahir les
États-Unis il lui suffirait d'inonder le
pays avec de la drogue il n'aurait pas
besoin de tirer un seul coup
alors quand vous arrêtez les gens et que
vous les enfermez loin de leurs proches
là vous obtenez des résultats
quand il voit leur famille au parloir là
il se disent je ne le ferai plus jamais
pour assurer sa réélection le shérif
fait donc du chiffre ce qui n'a pas
empêché de perdre les élections
au palais de justice de la
Nouvelle-Orléans nous sommes pas la loi
en Louisiane est l'une des plus dures du
pays on veille à ce que les prisons
soient bien remplis car pour chaque
détenus l'État fédéral verse 25 dollars
par jour
résultat à la Nouvelle-Orléans un adulte
sur 86 et derrière les barreaux c'est le
double de la moyenne nationale le
business est prison fait vivre beaucoup
de monde même des compagnies privées qui
se sont spécialisées dans le pré
d'argent pour sortir de prison sous
caution
[Musique]
Carpenter est un avocat commis d'office
lui et sa collègue sont payés par l'État
pour assurer la défense des 85%
d'inculpés qui n'ont pas les moyens de
se payer un avocat
Zac et New Yorkais il s'est installé
dans le Sud pour y accomplir ce qu'il
considère comme une mission
les injustices sont tellement grandes
ici en Louisiane à la Nouvelle-Orléans
ici on donne les peines les plus lourdes
de tous les États-Unis
c'est injuste mais c'est comme ça
alors nous les avocats nous venons
jusqu'ici pour lutter contre cette
injustice
c'est un challenge
Zac nous conduit à Saint-Roch un
quartier noir l'un des plus pauvres de
la ville
c'est ici que deux de ses clients ont
été arrêtés selon la police il
dissimulait de la drogue
Zac et son enquêtrice reviennent sur les
lieux de leur arrestation à la recherche
du moindre élément qui pourrait les
innocenter
il faut baisser la caméra
d'après le procès-verbal ça s'est passé
derrière cette maison
[Applaudissements]
les deux clients de zinc se serait faux
filés par ce passage étroit pour
échapper aux policiers ils auraient été
rattrapés au fond de cette cour
en fait on dirait qu'en passant par ici
on se retrouve dans l'autre bloc de
maison
mais qu'est-ce que vous cherchez
exactement
on essaie de visualiser ce qu'on
déclarait les policiers
ils disent qu'ils les ont poursuivi
jusqu'ici et que c'est là qu'ils
auraient trouvé de la drogue quelque
part dans un de ses jardins
dans une ville où les forces de l'ordre
ont l'obsession du chiffre il ne faut
pas toujours prendre la version des
policiers pour argent comptant
vous pensez que les policiers auraient
pu placer la drogue eux-mêmes
je crois que tout est possible par
exemple on peut aussi imaginer que les
habitants du quartier ont planqué de la
drogue à cet endroit-là et que les
policiers qui poursuivaient mes clients
l'ont trouvé en fouillant le coin
peut-être qu'ils ont décidé de leur
faire porter le chapeau moi je crois que
c'est ça
les policiers sont tentés de faire ce
genre de choses parce qu'on les
récompense quand ils ont du chiffre
à l'inverse s'il rentre bredouille ils
sont mal notés
ils ont clairement désintérêt qu'il faut
se la justice donc nous on est là pour
poser des questions qui fâchent
à la Nouvelle-Orléans la réputation de
la police est aussi sulfureuse que celle
de la ville incompétence corruption
malhonnêteté en tout genre
on a un officier de police qui a été
arrêté qui a du démissionner de la
police et qui vient de les découpable ce
type a fait disparaître des preuves dans
une affaire de meurtre d'un policier
c'est pas la première affaire
manifestement qui implique des policiers
de la Nouvelle-Orléans et
voici le bureau des avocats commis
d'office à mitsity au cœur de la ville
le quartier est entièrement dévoué à la
justice palais de justice prison
quartier général de la police le tout
dans un mouchoir de poche c'est pratique
dans ces locaux ils sont une
cinquantaine d'avocats spécialisés dans
la défense des démunis et c'est à
certains détails qu'on saisit la
complexité de leur mission
et pourquoi y a-t-il tant de vêtements
ici
mais en fait
ces vêtements c'est pour ceux de nos
clients qui sont trop pauvres pour avoir
de quoi s'habiller le jour du procès
comme ça ils n'ont pas honte de
ressembler à des indigents devant tout
le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ici à la prison d'Orléans Paris
que Zac se rend régulièrement pour
rencontrer ses clients
en moyenne il jongle en parallèle avec
92 chaque jour il défend 5 à 7 cas
devant le tribunal pour la seule année
2014 Zac et ses collègues ont défendu
21377 accusée des Noirs à 85%
notre système est conçu pour cibler les
quartiers pauvres essentiellement habité
par des Afro-Américains
et comme notre loi est très sévère avec
les récidivistes si vous êtes arrêté une
fois la police prend vos coordonnées vos
empreintes vous êtes fichés et après on
ne vous lâche plus la police squatte
votre quartier vous pouvez enfreindre la
loi dans bien des quartiers de La
Nouvelle-Orléans vous ne risquez
pratiquement rien car la police n'est
pas là elle n'est que dans les quartiers
pauvres ou vivent les Noirs
il n'y a que trois parloirs avocats dans
les murs de la prison
[Musique]
comment ça va John
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ça va
est-ce que c'est un bon avocat et même
si il est gratuit
comment ça va je vais bien ça va
pour préparer la défense de son nouveau
client Zac n'aura que 10 minutes ça a
plaidoirie sera encore plus courte en
moyenne les juges accordent aux avocats
7 minutes par dossier
étrange justice ou la défense
économétrée où les avocats commis
d'offices doivent faire appel à des dons
sur internet pour continuer à exercer
leur métier
[Musique]
il est temps pour moi de plonger dans
les prisons les plus sombres de la ville
[Musique]
des militants vont me raconter qu'ici
mieux vaut encore avoir la peau blanche
quand on est noir on peut mourir sous
les balles de la police sans raison
enfin je croiserai les fantômes du Ku
Klux Klan qui ne sont jamais loin
ces vêtements se sont enflammés et la
seule partie de son corps qui n'a pas
brûlé c'est la plante de ses pieds
avant d'entrer tout à l'heure dans la
nouvelle prison flambant neuve j'ai
droit à une visite de l'ancienne prison
qui a fonctionné jusqu'à l'été 2015 des
prisons pourris j'en ai vu beaucoup
celle-là dépasse l'entendement
[Musique]
cette prison a été construite dans les
années 20
le bâtiment a dû être occupé pour la
première fois en 1925
là c'est la tour de guet
[Musique]
en compagnie de Philippe Stelly le
chargé de communication du shérif
j'entre dans ce qui est désormais un
bâtiment administratif
vous rentrez dans une vraie prison merci
de vous prévenir
[Musique]
ici c'était les salles de jour
c'est là qu'il passait toute leur
journée tous ensemble oui
il y a pas de lumière on voit rien oui
c'est assez moche
mec qui pissaient devant tout le monde
vous imaginez l'odeur
surtout l'été quand il faisait très
chaud tout le bâtiment soit
ils étaient logés ici c'était plutôt sûr
donc il dormait ici et il passait le
reste du temps dans les cellules du jour
dans la salle commune
[Musique]
ce genre de prison j'en ai vu dans les
pays du tiers-monde
c'est pour ça qu'on était pressé de
quitter cet endroit et de construire une
prison moderne
[Musique]
paradoxalement c'est grâce à Katrina que
les détenus ont aujourd'hui de
meilleures conditions de vie l'ouragan
avait dévasté l'ancienne prison 10 ans
et 85 millions de dollars plus tard une
maison d'arrêt
ultra moderne et sortie de terre un
complexe bourré d'électronique et de
technologie de pointe entièrement dédiée
à la surveillance
ici c'est la salle de contrôle on a plus
de 800 caméras de surveillance braquées
sur les moindres recoins de la prison
[Musique]
direction la zone de détention à l'autre
bout d'un immense couloir
on arrive dans le hall central
dans cette maison d'arrêt un peu plus de
1200 détenus répartis sur 8 étages qui
attendent pour la plupart d'être jugé
avant de partir en établissement de
peine
à cette heure-ci les détenus sont en
cellule
pour pénétrer dans un des quartiers où
ils sont confinés par groupe de 60 plus
besoin de clés dans l'interphone une
voie électronique
au contrôle central veuillez ouvrir la
porte 1 à et un B
[Musique]
il y a des cellules et une salle de jeux
nous avons un petit centre de contrôle
d'où le surveillant commande les portes
des cellules et même toute la tuyauterie
donc en cas de crise on peut facilement
isoler le problème
mais pour les détenus la nouvelle prison
n'a peut-être pas que des avantages car
l'inconfort et l'insécurité de la
vieille maison d'arrêt à succédé le
sentiment d'être épié et contrôlé en
permanence
les crochets de ces étagères sont anti
suicide c'est pour protéger les détenus
ce wikipé
là à ces étagères en fait si on se pense
les étagères mais la d'étagère se
décroche quoi
donc ça c'est la cour de promenade c'est
ça
ce que vous entendez là c'est
l'autoroute d'ici on peut voir l'herbe
pour les détenus c'est important de
pouvoir regarder l'extérieur
mais on voit rien d'ici
on a une meilleure vue depuis les états
supérieurs
contrairement à la France les familles
n'ont pas accès à la prison les visites
se font dans un local situé à une
centaine de mètres du bâtiment principal
les détenus et leurs familles ne se
touchent pas ne se voient pas bienvenue
dans le monde parloir virtuelle
il se sépare en contact vidéo seulement
oui seulement par vidéo on ne voit
jamais la personne en vrai il existe
aucune possibilité de contact entre la
famille et le détenu absolument aucune
[Musique]
cette prison du futur est le navire
amiral de la pénitentiaire de la
Nouvelle-Orléans son capitaine est le
shérif Marlyn gussmann membre du Parti
démocrate Guzman à la réputation d'être
progressiste mais lorsqu'il s'agit de
critiquer même légèrement le système il
s'est resté très prudent
c'est la Louisiane c'est vrai et
peut-être un état qui incarce beaucoup
mais moi ce que je fais c'est que je me
contente d'obéir aux ordres
vous vous en tenez aux ordres
au maximum votre prison
fermer des gens qui n'ont rien à y faire
ça c'est votre avis c'est pas la vie
générale
je pense que c'est en train de
s'arranger je pense que ça change
si vous regardez les chiffres il y a
moins de gens en prison aujourd'hui que
deux ou trois ans en arrière
et je trouve ça très positif
on m'a dit que beaucoup de prison
voulait faire le plein de détenus pour
obtenir plus d'argent est-ce que c'est
vrai
je ne peux parler que pour moi
ici on dispose de 1444 litres mais on
n'a que 1250 détenus
donc si on voulait vraiment faire de
l'argent oui vous prendriez 200 détenus
de plus quoi oui 200 de plus mais vous
ne le faites pas non
nous ne le faisons pas en fait nous ne
faisons pas parce que ce n'est pas un
problème d'argent c'est un problème de
sécurité publique attention je ne suis
pas en train de vous dire que d'autres
prisons ne le font pas mais moi je ne
peux pas parler pour les autres
le discours du shérif fait peut-être
encourageant mais la révolution n'est
pas encore à l'oeuvre dans les prisons
de la Nouvelle-Orléans car le système
considère toujours qu'un détenu est une
source de profit
[Musique]
quelques mois avant leur sortie
définitive les prisonniers bénéficient
en général d'un régime de semis liberté
ils sont lâchés dans la ville pour
travailler dans des entreprises avant de
regagner la prison le soir
situé à deux pas de la prison ce
restaurant accueille régulièrement une
main d'oeuvre bon marché que lui fournit
la maison d'arrêt
[Musique]
Donald Johnson travaille en cuisine
depuis quelques mois un boulot qui lui
permet de préparer son retour à la
liberté
je suis en train de préparer des
crevettes et des beignets d'oignons
Donald est tombé pour possession de
crack il n'avait jamais travaillé dans
un restaurant ses collègues qui l'ont
plutôt bien accueilli lui ont appris le
métier
voici Miss Vanessa
et elle s'est mise rénaleda comment
allez-vous
il vient de la même prison que moi j'ai
commencé comme lui
comme chez nous une partie du salaire
des détenus sert à payer les frais de
justice et à indemniser les victimes
mais ici la prison prélève aussi sa part
du gâteau
je travaille 8 heures par jour et vous
gagnez combien de l'heure
je gagne 3 dollars et demi de l'heure
ils prennent quasiment 80 % de notre
revenu
60 % mais en fait ils nous embrouille
entre le brut et le net
et donc en vrai il nous pique 80% nous
on gagne presque rien
de dollars de leur en gros on devrait
gagner entre 500 et 600 dollars chaque
semaine mais on touche que 140 dollars
on travaille presque gratuitement pour
eux tu vois
moi je trouve que c'est pas bien en fait
on nous arrête on nous met en prison et
on nous fait travailler pour engraisser
l'État
tous les soirs après le travail Donald
regagne le centre McLaren un dortoir qui
dépend de la prison c'est là qu'il passe
le reste de ses journées avec ses codes
tenues en attendant une libération
définitive
[Musique]
grâce à ce travail j'ai une réduction de
peine j'apprends un métier j'envoie le
bout je serais bientôt libre
condamné en 2013 à deux ans et demi de
prison Donald doit sortir dans quelques
mois
[Musique]
les candidats à la broyeuse carcérale
c'est dans les quartiers comme celui de
Saint-Roch quand les trouve le taux
d'homicide est ici deux fois supérieur
au reste de la ville
aujourd'hui la mairie soutenue par
l'université a décidé de mener une
opération de communication pour
réaffirmer sa volonté de lutter contre
la criminalité
nights prime les chevaliers contre le
crime
tout un programme
[Musique]
cet événement auquel a été convié la
presse se résume à une grande kermesse
une belle fanfare le gratin de la ville
tous les organes de sécurité et bien sûr
Monsieur le Maire au discours bien rodé
je vous remercie d'être venu si nombreux
pour cette opération chevalier contrôle
crime je veux remercier notre chef de la
police et tous les chefs du département
de police les narcotiques le FBI les
mars c'est toute une équipe qui a sur
notre sécurité mais la justice et la
police ne peuvent pas tout régler vous
pouvez nous aider à faire de la
Nouvelle-Orléans une ville sur
mais tout le monde ne partage pas
l'enthousiasme du maire
ce groupe de militants en t-shirt orange
ce sont les pistes peopers des grands
frères version Black Power plusieurs
fois par semaine Walter
umrami arpente le quartier avec son
groupe il distribue des tracts et
propose son aide pour résoudre les
conflits et remettre les jeunes dans le
droit chemin
la plupart des gamins ne connaissent pas
ça
ne veulent pas prendre part à la
kermesse
[Musique]
qui joue au ballon avec un gamin
il a l'air d'un brave type qui joue au
football avec un gosse
c'est beau n'est-ce pas
tout le temps nous devrions avoir des
policiers de proximité qui reste dans le
quartier des flics qui établiraient des
relations avec les habitants
on se bat pour quelque chose de plus
important que ce que fait le maire de
plus important que ce que fait la police
ce que vous voyez là aujourd'hui c'est
un show un truc politique
ça fera tout juste un bel article dans
le journal
notre père nous sommes venus aujourd'hui
au nom de Jésus pour que tu bénisses
notre communauté béni notre mère notre
conseil municipal nos officiels élus
nous condamnons le crime Jésus a dit
aucune arme tournée contre nous ne
pourra vaincre merci Dieu amen frapper
dans vos mains maintenant s'il vous
plaît en signe de victoire
des deux côtés de la rue deux visions
irréconciliables pour les uns le salut
viendra de Dieu et de la police pour les
autres ce sont les militants dans la rue
qui transformeront le système
partager ça avec vos fils il y a de
vrais opportunités pour eux la plupart
des gamins dans les quartiers difficiles
ne connaissent pas ces bourses à
l'emploi
j'apprécie votre geste parce que je
ferai tout pour mon fils mon mari a été
assassiné deux semaines avant Katrina
mon fils a 16 ans je veux absolument
qu'il reste motivé
merci beaucoup mon numéro personnel est
derrière appelez-moi si vous avez besoin
d'aide
je le ferai merci beaucoup
un seul vrai bénévole en fait plus
qu'une armée de fonctionnaires de la
ville ou du gouvernement
je ne suis pas contre la police
mais notre communauté et surtout les
jeunes qui sont dans la rue ils ont une
relation compliquée avec la police il ne
lui font pas confiance
chez les Noirs c'est installé un mélange
de défiance et de peur
car ici on peut perdre la vie simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas la bonne couleur de
peau
parmi les affaires les plus
retentissantes celle du pont de
dancinger qui a marqué durablement les
esprits
tout commence le 29 août 205 au matin
lorsque Katrina le sixième ouragan le
plus puissant jamais enregistré au monde
s'abat sur la Nouvelle-Orléans les dix
sautes des quartiers entiers parmi
lesquels beaucoup de quartiers pauvres
sont engloutés il y aura 1836 morts et
140 000 sinistrés
dans les jours qui suivent le chaos
s'empare de la ville des dizaines de
milliers de naufragés sont livrés à
eux-mêmes
[Musique]
c'était cinq jours après la tempête il
n'y avait plus d'électricité plus d'eau
plus de nourriture et toutes les
conditions étaient réunies pour que les
gens les plus vilains puissent commettre
les pires vilenies
pendant plusieurs jours les services de
la ville sont dépassés y compris la
police le 4 septembre 2005 deux familles
de la communauté noire les bartolomio et
les Madison empruntent le pendant de
singer
donc on est sur le pont où tout est
arrivé
il traversait le pont en direction d'un
supermarché
y trouver de la nourriture
quelqu'un a appelé la police pour dire
que des gens tiraient sur des policiers
prix de panique la police a débarqué à
toute vitesse dans un camion de location
normal
les policiers ont bondir hors du camion
un agent avec une kalachnikov un autre
avait un fusil à pompe il n'avait aucune
preuve il n'avait pas été provoqué mais
ils ont tiré sur les gens qui étaient
sur le pont
ils n'en fait aucune sommation rien ils
les ont juste massacrés
5 membres de la famille bartolomiou son
grièvement blessés James Brissette 17
ans a mis de la famille et tué sur le
coup
Ronald Madison handicapé mental essaye
de s'enfuir il est abattu à son tour
l'homme qu'ils ont tué ronaldison ils
lui ont tiré dans le dos avec un fusil à
pompe
au cours d'un premier procès les quatre
policiers qui ont ouvert le feu sur le
pont de dancinger sont condamnés à des
peines légères depuis
ceepers l'organisation à laquelle
j'appartiens n'a qu'un seul but en finir
avec la violence dans les quartiers le
plus souvent ce sont des Noirs qui tuent
des Noirs mais comment voulez-vous que
j'explique à ces jeunes gangrené par la
violence que leur vie vaut quelque chose
comment je peux leur prêcher ça alors
que la police peut leur tirer dessus en
toute impunité
il voit ça et il se disent ma vie ne
vaut rien
en 2011 a lieu le procès en appel du
pont de dancinger cette fois il est
démontré que les quatre policiers ont
tenté de dissimuler des indices et des
preuves ils sont condamnés à des peines
comprise entre 38 et 65 ans de prison
pour avoir falsifié son rapport
l'inspecteur qui a mené l'enquête et
cote d'une peine de 6 ans mais en 2015
la condamnation est cassée il y aura
donc un troisième procès
auront bientôt droit à un nouveau procès
c'est la preuve que d'une façon ou d'une
autre on veut leur acquittement
donc le message est toujours le même
vous avez le droit de tuer un homme ou
une femme noire
l'épicekeepers considère que l'abolition
de l'esclavage et la lutte pour les
droits civiques des années 60 non rien
changé
les pouvoirs en place je veux dire le
pouvoir blanc
n'acceptera jamais d'accorder l'égalité
à ses anciens esclaves
jamais
l'affaire du pont de dancinger n'est pas
un cas isolé toujours pendant Katrina un
peu plus au sud dans le quartier
d'algers la police a abattu un autre
noir sans raison j'ai rendez-vous avec
son beau-frère
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes Bernard oui je suis
Bernard Calloway comment ça va je suis
Christophe Bernard Calloway a vu sa vie
basculer le 2 septembre 2005 lorsque lui
et son beau-frère ont été pris sous le
feu d'un tireur invisible qui plus tard
s'avéra être un policier vous avez tout
perdu avec l'ouragan
sa maison et sa vie
Enrique lover était un homme de 31 ans
il vivait avec sa mère son frère et sa
sœur trois jours après Katrina il
s'apprêtait à évacuer la ville il était
allé avec son beau-frère récupérer des
affaires il n'est jamais revenu Bernard
est resté traumatisé à jamais
[Musique]
depuis je suis très angoissé j'ai peur
ça m'a donné des troubles de stress
post-traumatique
je suis devenu dépressif ça fait 10 ans
que ça dure maintenant
je vis complètement reclus ça me fait
souffrir parce que je suis seul
je suis tout seul
justement et mon chien
10 ans plus tard Bernard vit sous
médicament il ne sort jamais de chez lui
[Musique]
oui c'est là que je passe tout mon temps
c'est votre chambre
toute ma vie est là
[Musique]
depuis qu'il a assisté à la mort de son
beau-frère il vitrait dans ce deux
pièces
tétanisé par les menaces de mort qui la
reçus de la police
ah vous avez un chien
avec lui vous devez pas avoir de
problème
non elle tient les étrangers à distance
elle leur fait peur
qui viennent là derrière ou des
alcooliques
mais elle leur fait peur
moi je comprends elle fait aussi peur
aux flics je suppose
[Musique]
Bernard accepte de nous conduire en
compagnie de son avocate sur les lieux
où tout a basculé quand les dix ont
cédés c'est la société entière qui a
cédé
il y avait plus d'eau potable
plus
il y avait des cadavres qui jonchent les
rues
[Musique]
moi j'avais l'impression que c'était la
fin du monde qui s'abattait sur ma ville
c'était complètement dingue on aurait
dit de Walking Dead la police
patrouillée pour tuer ce qui ressemblait
à des zombies mais ça n'était pas des
zombies c'était des vrais gens qui
cherchaient de l'aide et il n'y avait
personne pour les aider
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce jour-là Bernard avait décidé
d'accompagner Henry Glover avec un petit
camion pour récupérer quelques affaires
qui avaient disposé sur le trottoir
on a amené le camion jusqu'ici
il a mis la marche arrière et il a
reculé comme ça
je crois que c'est à peu près là qu'il
s'est arrêté
je suis descendu comme ça
le panier qu'on devait charger était là
je me suis penché pour attraper le
panier
j'ai entendu
j'ai regardé j'ai vu qu'en Henri était
touché il courait vers là-bas
imaginons que je suis en vie
j'ai regardé vers l'endroit d'où venait
le tir parce que je ne comprenais
toujours pas
alors il est tombé ici il était encore
vivant oui il était vivant et vous
pouviez voir où il avait été blessé il
était touché à la poitrine il a fait
comme ça
et il est tombé les derniers mots qu'il
m'a dit c'est dit à ma mère que je
l'aime
ça va
quelle saloperie
j'ai rien vu le temps de me retourner
c'était fini
donc il était quelque part là-haut oui
il était quelque part à l'étage
[Musique]
il n'a pas fait de sommation non il
était à l'affût il chassait avec son
arme personnelle oui son arme de service
n'était pas assez précise alors il est
allé chercher chez lui un fusil de
tireur d'élite
et c'est avec ça qu'il a tué Glover
donc il était quelque part par là mais
vous n'avez jamais pu le voir je n'ai
jamais vu je n'ai jamais su à quoi il
ressemblait jusqu'au jour du procès
[Musique]
le sniper le voici David Warren un
policier que la ville venait de recruter
après l'ouragan son unité avait
réquisitionné une école pour y installer
un poste de secours et c'est justement
là que Bernard callanet aidé par son
voisin décide de transporter son
beau-frère agonisant pour tenter de le
sauver
[Musique]
donc c'est l'école en question et vous
êtes arrivés de ce côté Bernard
ils nous ont braqué avec leurs armes et
on s'est allongé par terre on essayait
de leur dire qu'il y avait eu un meurtre
mais on devait être tempéré
et ils nous ont mis les notes
attendez une seconde il ne vous ont rien
demandé non ils vous ont tout de suite
mené
ça
j'ai essayé juste de sauver mon
beau-frère
personne ne s'en occupait
et pendant ce temps-là Henri était
toujours dans la voiture non il avait
déjà emmené
il avait mis dans une autre voiture et
je ne l'ai plus jamais revu
[Musique]
un peu plus tard on retrouvera la
Chevrolet Malibu à bord de laquelle
Henry Glover a été évacué par la police
le véhicule a été incendié avec à son
bord un corps décapité celui d'Enrique
ils ont séparé sa tête de son corps et
il l'ont brûlé
mais pourquoi diable
et on n'a jamais retrouvé sa tête
[Musique]
et vous avez demandé à des avocats de
mener l'enquête j'ai contacté des tas
d'avocats dans le coin mais personne n'a
voulu nous aider
condamné à 25 ans de prison Warren fait
appel rejugés en 2013 il est a quitté
la première chose qu'il a dit devant les
journalistes c'est que s'il fallait le
refaire il le refait
ce type ne se sent même pas coupable
il a simplement dit ça aux journalistes
avec un grand sourire
selon lui il a fait son boulot mais son
boulot c'était pas d'aller chez lui
chercher cette arme de guerre et de tuer
mon beau-frère
désolé j'ai pas pu te sauver
[Musique]
Bernard et son avocate sont convaincus
que des policiers de l'école ont tout
fait pour couvrir Warren et qu'ils ont
fait disparaître la tête de la victime
pour qu'on ne puisse jamais l'identifier
as senti qu'il pouvait faire ce dont il
avait toujours rêvé se débarrasser de
ceux qui a ses yeux ne respectez pas le
système
et Katrina lui en a donné l'occasion
quoi exactement
c'était un chasseur expérimenté pour lui
il n'y avait pas de différence entre
Henri Glover
et un gibier
[Musique]
des affaires à caractère racial qui ne
seront jamais soldés par une décision de
justice équitable l'histoire de la
Nouvelle-Orléans et de la Louisiane en
regorge un Rolant d'une époque pas si
lointaine où les Noirs luttaient encore
pour l'égalité des droits civiques
à l'université de Baton Rouge un homme
s'est fait une spécialité de ses
affaires non résolues
et professeur de journalisme et avec
quelques étudiants il a constitué une
équipe pour travailler sur des Cold Case
des affaires survenues dans les années
50 et 60 et que le FBI n'a pas réussi à
résoudre
les gens du Sud se divisent en deux
catégories
ce qui ne veulent absolument pas
entendre parler de cette époque et ceux
qui à mon avis
veulent en savoir plus
qui ne veulent pas oublier
un peu comme les gens qui cherchent à
comprendre l'Holocauste
[Musique]
des affaires sordides dans lesquelles
plaines souvent l'ombre du Ku Klux Klan
ça ce sont des gens du Ku Klux Klan à
l'époque on en a identifié quelques-uns
dans les années 20 le Ku Klux Klan a
compté jusqu'à 5 millions de membres
cette organisation raciste d'extrême
droite était présente partout dans le
sud plus tard dans les années 60 quand
les Noirs ont commencé à se battre pour
leur droit civiques la tension est
devenue maximum y compris dans les
campagnes de Louisiane où vivaient un
certain Frank Morris
était un gars dont l'entreprise marchait
bien il était installé à Fairy Day et il
avait une cordonnerie
il avait trois fois mieux réussi dans la
vie que la plupart de ces types du clan
c'était plutôt des ratés qui avaient des
petites vies minables
ils étaient jaloux ouais
et donc Franck le cordonnier avait des
mauvaises relations avec le shérif du
coin
un certain Franck de l'auteur
c'était un gros type le genre qui aurait
réussi à Hollywood dans un casting où
l'on aurait cherché une caricature de
gros redneck ce gars était corrompu et
c'était aussi un membre du clan
[Musique]
un jour le shérif est allé voir Franck
avec une paire de bottes de cow-boy et
il lui a demandé de les réparer
mais il a exigé que ce soit fait
gratuitement le cordonnier avait déjà
cédé une ou deux fois mais cette fois là
il a refusé
il en avait assez il lui a dit de payer
comme tout le monde
[Musique]
alors une nuit il a entendu du bruit et
il a senti une odeur d'essence
il est tombé sur deux gares mais de
revolver qui lui ont ordonné de rentrer
dans la boutique
[Musique]
puis ils ont mis feu à la maison avec
Franck Morris dedans
ces vêtements se sont enflammés et la
seule partie de son corps qui n'a pas
brûlé c'est la plante de ses pieds
[Musique]
le FBI a fait une enquête mais pas la
police locale
ça c'est sur Frank Morris
il y a aussi d'autres infos sur le clan
de l'époque
en 2007 le Congrès américain vote la
réouverture d'une centaine d'enquêtes
non résolues il y a des violences
raciales
depuis 2010 date à laquelle il a créé le
projet Cold Case James travaille avec
une trentaine d'étudiants autorisés à
accéder aux rapports du FBI à ce jour le
projet Cold Case a aidé à résoudre une
douzaine d'affaires
c'est votre équipe oui c'est une petite
équipe pour un petit bureau
l'équipe a affiché au mur cette lettre
c'est un appel au secours adressé au
chef du FBI de l'époque edgar Hoover par
la communauté noire de Fairy Tail après
l'affaire Franck Maurice
régulièrement la petite équipe sillonne
la région pour rencontrer des témoins
susceptibles de relancer ou en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui de compléter
une enquête
on en est où avec le clan aujourd'hui il
est toujours présent dans la région
individuellement il y a des gens qui
revendiquent leur appartenance au clan
mais ce sont des amateurs ça ne veut pas
dire qu'ils ne sont pas haineux mais ils
sont peu nombreux
aujourd'hui ils sont tout juste capables
de continuer à effrayer les gens qui ont
connu l'époque dont nous parlons
ce garage situé à quelques kilomètres de
Fairy Tail est la propriété de Robert
Mathus
dans les années 60 Matthews était un
militant de la cause noire il a bien
connu la victime Franck Maurice
l'équipe du projet Cold Case est venu
enregistrer son témoignage il cherche
des pistes qui auraient pu être négligés
volontairement ou non par les enquêteurs
de l'époque
parlez-moi de Franck Maurice et de ce
qui s'est réellement passé
le shérif se sont embrouillés pour une
histoire de bottes
donc le shérif est bien entrer dans la
boutique
oui oui tout le monde sait ça
et c'était discuté pour une histoire de
bottes de cow-boy et le shérif avait
menacé de se venger
vous pouvez me dire qui a rendu visite à
Franck cette nuit-là
un de mes amis qui habitaient en face a
dit qu'il avait vu le shérif qui
essayait de le faire sortir mais c'est
le shérif qui l'a tué
le shérif et qui d'autre
[Applaudissements]
pas de l'autre
c'est grâce à ce travail de fourmis que
le projet gold case a retrouvé en 2012
la trace de cet homme
Léonard Spencer l'un des bourreaux de
Frank Morris à droite Stanley Nelson un
journaliste du Concordia Sentinel un
journal régional en s'appuyant sur les
travaux du projet Cold Case il a fait
surgir le cas Frank Morris dans les
colonnes de son journal
l'enquête a fait tellement de bruit que
son auteur a été classé 3e dans la
course aux Politzer
dans son article trois témoins
confirment la participation de Spencer
au meurtre de Franck Morris avec une
équipe de Ku Klux Klan les assassins
auront aspergé Maurice d'essence avant
de l'enflammer et de lui crier course à
[ __ ] cours
une telle révélation plus de 50 ans
après les faits montre que l'on peut
encore agir
c'est notre dernière chance de résoudre
ces affaires et de trouver toutes les
infos que nous pouvons
car les témoins et les suspects sont en
train de disparaître le pays encore une
petite chance de faire la lumière sur
ses meurtres nous pouvons écrire une
histoire précise car jusqu'à présent
cette histoire n'a pas été écrite mais
l'idée c'est d'inculper quelqu'un c'est
d'attraper les responsables de les juger
de les mettre en prison
il est beaucoup plus satisfaisant
d'arriver à faire le deuil de ces
histoires que de mettre quelqu'un en
prison
je sais que récemment un type a été mis
en prison il est mort quelques temps
après
quand il s'agit d'un vieil homme comme
ça ça n'apporte pas grand chose de le
mettre en prison moi je pense que faire
le deuil c'est plus important
moi je n'ai aucun souci à mettre un
vieux de en prison s'il est coupable
âgé de 71 ans lorsqu'on a retrouvé sa
trace Spencer n'aura pas eu le temps de
connaître la famille d'une condamnation
il est mort avant
[Musique]
en 2013 le FBI a définitivement refermé
le dossier Frank Morris
[Musique]
il est temps pour moi de quitter les
berges du Mississippi et cette Louisiane
dans l'histoire n'a rien d'un fleuve
tranquille à l'aube des années 2000 la
Nouvelle-Orléans semblait enfin capable
de tourner le dos à son destin
[Musique]
mais l'ouragan Katrina a ruiné les
efforts de ce qui veillaient sur la cité
la ville a replongé dans la nuit du
crime elle reste sans doute pour
longtemps encore l'une des plus
sulfureuses des États-Unis
[Musique]